Trust yourself, hier ist Chaosradio Express, die Ausgabe Nummer 5, eine kleine Sonderausgabe. Wir wollen heute nochmal ganz dediziert über das Konferenzprogramm des kommenden Chaos Communication Congresses reden und im Einzelnen einzelne Veranstaltungen vorstellen, damit ihr ein bisschen einen Einblick bekommt, was auf der Veranstaltung alles passieren wird und schon mal planen könnt, wo ihr hingeht. Die wilde Musik im Hintergrund ist von Symbiosis, ein Live-Set und die Gruppe wird auch auf dem Kongress vertreten sein. Und ich bin heute auch nicht alleine am Start, sondern habe Besuch bekommen von Fukami. Hallo Fukami.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir wollen mal ein bisschen auf den Kongress eingehen, auf das Konferenzprogramm. Du warst ja glaube ich in diesem Jahr derjenige, der dem Konferenzprogramm der ganzen Planung deutlich am nächsten am nächsten stehst, am nächsten gestanden hast, immer noch stehst. Eigentlich ist ja jetzt gerade die heiße Phase. Wie fertig ist das Kongressprogramm?
Na, es hat jetzt Version 0.9.9 erreicht. Wir haben schon ein paar kleine Bugs festgestellt beim Export, aber bis auf zwei Vorträge, die wir gerne im Programm haben wollen, ist eigentlich alles klar. Jetzt haben wir noch die letzten Tage ein paar Late-Bragger mit reingenommen, aber jetzt warten wir noch auf diese beiden Sachen und dann sind wir wirklich bei der Version 1.0 ungefähr, naja, so zweieinhalb Wochen vor Kongressbeginn.
Ok, 099. Eigentlich setzen wir ja einen neuen Rekord, kommt uns das irgendwie gar nicht mehr so richtig vor, aber früher war es immer die Tradition, das Kongressprogramm möglichst geheim zu halten. Das ist jetzt vorbei, alles steht im Web unter events.ccc.de, Kongress 2005. Dort könnt ihr euch den Fahrplan anschauen und vielleicht holt ihr die Webseite jetzt schon mal hoch, bevor wir dann auf die einzelnen Tage eingehen. Ja, bevor wir vielleicht auch auf das Programm selber zu sprechen kommen, es gibt auch noch ein paar interessante Features, zum Beispiel unter 22c3.fholzhauer.de wartet der Lecture Reminder für die Leute von euch, die die Java benutzen, das Instant Messaging Protokoll, gibt es die Möglichkeit, sich auf die Veranstaltung quasi live draufzuschalten, wenn sich da was ändert, kriegt man das automatisch mitgeteilt, wenn man einen Java Client benutzt. Hast du es schon mal ausprobiert? Da war das schon am Start, ne? Aber das ist jetzt glaube ich nochmal komplett überarbeitet worden und hat auch eine interessante Übersicht. Alle Links dieser Sendung kommen natürlich wieder in den Lyrics, der MP3-Datei mit und finden sich auch direkt im Podcast-Feed. Wenn ihr das nicht mit iTunes liest, dann... Ah doch, bei iTunes ist das dann auch sichtbar. So, ja, was ist neu? Neu ist auf jeden Fall, dass der Kongress dieses Jahr einen Tag länger ist, vier Tage. Wir haben den 30. Dezember noch mit dazugenommen. Das hat verschiedene Gründe gehabt. Einer der Gründe ist der, dass wir einfach die Veranstaltung insgesamt etwas, ja, entzerren wollten. Es war, es ist immer eine extreme Dichte auf dem Kongress. Es ist sehr viel los, sehr viele Leute, die man trifft, la la la, und dazu eben noch das dicht gepackte Veranstaltungsprogramm und das schrie ein bisschen nach mehr Pausen. Und die werden dadurch entstehen, dass das ganze Programm sich jetzt auf vier Tage verteilt. Dazu kommt auch noch, dass wir den Tag selber etwas entzerren. Einerseits fangen wir noch eine Stunde später an, weil es nach einiger Zeit dann immer so Aufstehprobleme einstellen. Und es gibt auch noch eine zweite Pause. Erste Pause, 15 Uhr, zweite Pause, 20 Uhr. Und dazwischen dann immer Blöcke von drei und vier Stunden Vortragsprogramm in vier Sälen. Es gibt auch ein paar regelmäßige Dinge, zum Beispiel die Lightning Talks. Hast du da schon mal einen Blick drauf gehabt?
Ja, die Lightning Talks sind immer...
Vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was das ist?
Also Lightning Talks sind 5 Minuten Vorträge, wo die Leute, die da Vorträge halten, ihre Sachen kurz vorstellen können oder auch über noch Unfertiges reden können und ja eben einfach Ideen teilen. Das Schöne an der Art von Veranstaltungen ist, dass man zum einen innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit sehr viele verschiedene Sachen aufnehmen kann und nach 5 Minuten auch... Ja, eigentlich so ein Punkt erreicht ist, wo man sagt, wenn man so ein paar Basics irgendwie erklären will, das sollte 5 Minuten gesagt sein. Und ein anderer großer Vorteil daran ist halt auch, wenn mal ein Vortrag nicht so spannend ist vielleicht oder so oder es ist noch was anderes.
Dann ist es auch nicht so schlimm gewesen, dass man sich mal 5 Minuten geopfert hat.
Genau.
Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch mal gut besucht gewesen letztes Jahr. Wir haben Lightning Talks jeden Tag, immer um, was war es, 16 Uhr?
16 Uhr nach der Pause direkt.
Genau, eine Stunde.
Und immer in Saal 4, das ist unten beim Hackcenter.
Genau. Zusätzlich gibt es noch einen zweiten sich selbst gestaltenden Bereich, nämlich die Workshop Area, auch ganz unten hinter dem Hackcenter im letzten Raum. Dort können Leute sich auch, ich glaube, es ist schon voll, ich habe noch nicht geschaut, aber ich glaube, da ist noch was zu holen. Aber man kann eben auch freie Workshops eintragen, solange noch was zu holen ist. Wir machen das alles über unser Wiki. Zuerst kommt Mal zuerst. Das gilt für die Lightning Talks genauso wie für die Workshops.
Ja, zudem gibt es auch die Möglichkeit, wenn man auf dem Kongress merkt, man braucht vielleicht noch mal für 20, 30, 40 Leute, wie auch immer, die Möglichkeit, noch weiter zu diskutieren, die Möglichkeit in der C-Base auch noch mal einen Raum zu bekommen, um da zu reden.
Genau, die C-Base sollte man noch erwähnen. Die C-Base ist ein dem CCC nahestehender Verwandterverein. Dort geht es um die Wiederausgrabung eines Raumschiffs. Dazu könnte man später noch mal mehr erzählen. Das ist mindestens eine eigene Sendung wert. Aber C-Base ist integriert. Am letzten Tag findet dort auch unsere After Hour statt, die nach Kongressparty am 30.12., die auf jeden Fall auch wert ist, besucht zu werden. Während der Veranstaltung gibt es also die Möglichkeit, wenn Leute jetzt nicht direkt im Kontext des Kongresses, sondern wenn einfach noch mal ein Ort gesucht wird, wo man sich mit Leuten, die auch noch auf dem Kongress sind, noch mal in Ruhe mit irgendetwas auseinandersetzen will. Jenseits des Trubels gibt es die Möglichkeit, das dort zu machen. Wenn ihr da Interesse habt, solltet ihr euch an die Orga wenden. So, ja, fangen wir mal vorne an, würde ich sagen. Das ist so viel alles, aber wir wollen euch jetzt nicht jetzt wirklich alles erzählen. Ihr könnt das alles auf den Webseiten im Detail nachlesen, aber so die Linie und die Highlights, die wollen wir schon mal herausstellen. Es geht alles los mit der Keynote.
Ja, Joey Ito macht die Keynote in diesem Jahr. Joey war ja schon letztes Jahr da und hat über, was war das noch gleich? Was hat er da gesprochen?
Joey Ito hat letztes Jahr seinen Paper vorgestellt, Emergent Democracy. Joey Ito ist extrem bekannt in der Webblog-Szene und er hält natürlich ein eigenes Blog, aber ist eigentlich auch eher bekannt, weil er eben schon sehr lange dabei ist. Es ist so ein unermüdlicher Weltenreisender, der mit den ersten ISP gegründet hat in Japan und heute so in nahezu allen Gremien und Aufsichtsräten vertreten ist, wo es irgendwie heiß abgeht. Einerseits ist er jetzt auch in die ICAN gewählt worden, also die Rolle, die Andy mal vor zwei Jahren noch hatte, die hat er jetzt. Andererseits ist er auch so bei BitTorrent mit dabei, er ist bei SixApart, die Leute, die das Movable-Type-Weblog gemacht haben, also er steckt eigentlich überall drin, wo Spaß ist, ist total unermüdlich und war letztes Jahr das erste Mal auf dem Kongress, war total begeistert und hat sich dann von uns auch ohne Mühen breitschlagen lassen, unter dem Titel des Mottoes des diesjährigen Kongresses, Private Investigations, die Kino zu halten, was er uns da alles erzählen wird. Da sind wir selber sehr gespannt. Damit geht es auf jeden Fall los. Und dann haben wir jeden Tag gewisse Schwerpunkte. Die haben sich eigentlich jetzt so ein bisschen herausgestellt. Das haben wir nicht so sehr geplant, aber das ergibt sich einfach zwangsläufig aus der Sachlage. Großes Thema, ganz klar für den CCC dieses Jahr sowieso schon bisher gewesen und natürlich dann auch auf dem Kongress ist Biometrie und der neue elektronische Reisepass. Da haben wir am ersten Tag drei Vorträge schön verteilt. Magst du mal kurz was zu sagen?
Das fängt an mit dem Vortrag von Starbuck und Constanze über die Biop-2-Studie des BSI. Darüber wurde ja auch schon in der letzten, ja gerade in der vorletzten Datastrolle, wurde darüber ja schon eine ganze Ausgabe gemacht und das wird nochmal alles in dem Vortrag zusammengefasst und auch die ganzen Odds and Ends dieser gab, also mit den mehreren Versionen, die es gab und so weiter.
Genau, Biop2-Studie ist diese von der Bundeskriege geruhig aufgegebene Studie, mit deren Ergebnissen sie dann selber nicht so glücklich gewesen ist. Oder was das BSI was beauftragt hat? Das BMI hat zwei Auftragsprojekte. Naja, sowas erfahrt ihr dann alles in dem Vortrag. Genau, am Nachmittag macht Starbucks dann nochmal einen Vortrag zu der Technik, die jetzt in den neuen elektronischen Reisepass reinkommt, also was für Features da drin sind, wie das mit der RFID-Technik, mit der Ausleseverhinderung und so weiter bestellt ist, ja, was alles so passieren kann, dass ein solcher Pass nicht mehr funktioniert und ähnliche interessante Details. Und am Abend gibt es dann ein schönes Nachtprogramm, das macht dann wieder Konstanze. Das wird ganz nett, und zwar ist es eine, ja, mehr eine kulturelle Vorstellung. Es heißt offiziell Biometrics in Science Fiction. Es geht also um die Visionen, die biometrischen Visionen, die wir heute schon in Hollywood und anderen Filmproduktionen zu sehen bekommen haben, wie denn das mal so sein könnte. Gattaca, solche Namen sollten einem da gleich einfallen, aber da fällt einem noch ein paar mehr ein, und Konz wird das einfach mal vorstellen, was da schon alles gibt, und das wird auf jeden Fall eine sehr unterhaltsame Veranstaltung. Zweites großes Thema am ersten Tag ist die Gesundheitskarte. Hatten wir ja auch schon letztes Jahr, da hat das großen Wirbel gemacht. Der Vortrag von Thomas war letztes Jahr nur eine Stunde, hat aber eine ganze Menge aufgewirbelt. Und weil es dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich wieder auch eine ganze Menge aufwirbeln wird, ist es auch gleich ein Zwei-Stunden-Vortrag geworden.
Der Grund für die zwei Stunden ist vor allem, weil er dann während der Submission-Pace gesagt hat, er hat seine Folien angefangen und ist jetzt bei 90 und so, oder eine Stunde, ist halt ein bisschen knapp.
Okay, also er weiß da auf jeden Fall Bescheid, ist extrem mit der technischen Entwicklung und der ganzen Standardsplanung beschäftigt gewesen und wird eben über den aktuellen Stand der Entwicklung berichten. Es ist ja dann noch nichts final beschlossen, die Karte gibt es noch nicht.
Aber interessant in dem Zusammenhang, davor gibt es noch einen Vortrag von Karin Spank aus Holland. In Holland ist das ja schon eingeführt worden und sie erzählt so ein bisschen, was da so an Problemen existiert und wie man da auch Daten rausziehen kann aus den Sachen und wie man halt die ganze Geschichte hackt.
Also letztes Jahr gab es ja wirklich wilde Reaktionen. Also nach dem Kongress, ich erinnere mich noch, hat dann sogar der Virchobund, also der Verband der niedergelassenen Ärzte in Deutschland, so eine Organisation, die uns jetzt nicht, also nicht von sich aus heraus besonders nahe steht, hat dann irgendwie öffentlich postuliert, was haben sie geschrieben? Lalalala, Datenschutz und die Datensicherheit sind der Dreh- und Angelpunkt für Erfolg oder Misserfolg der Gesundheitskarte. Bis heute bekanntgewordene Risiken sprechen deutlich gegen ein Gelingen. Wenn wie berichtet Sicherheitsexperten bei einem Modellvorhaben zur Gesundheitskarte schwerwiegende Sicherheitslücken festgestellt haben, ist das ein Zeichen für die nicht ausreichende Konzeption. Proton letztes Jahr. Und dann meinten sie noch, jetzt müssen die beteiligten Praktikabilität, Datenschutz und Datensicherheit belegen und nicht nur behaupten. Und fügen noch hinzu, dazu sollten professionelle Hacker engagiert werden, wie etwa Mitglieder des bekannten Chaos Computer Club aus Hamburg. Das haben die in ihr Pressrelease reingeschrieben. Also nicht, wir haben noch nichts mit zu tun gehabt. Also lieber Wirchebund, das ist zwar schon ein bisschen her, aber dazu kann man gleich noch mal sagen. Erstens kommt der CTC nicht aus Hamburg, sondern aus Deutschland, wenn überhaupt. Und Showhacks machen wir schon gar nicht. Also lasst uns hier nicht für den Karren spannen. Aber wenn ihr den wollt, zumindest schön zu sehen, dass der Kongress an der Stelle voll eingeschlagen hat. Und wir werden dieses Jahr sicherlich noch mal ähnliche Querschieße haben. Okay, das ist die Gesundheitskarte. Drittes großes Thema am ersten Tag ist Videoüberwachung. Da gibt es ja auch so einiges. Los geht das mit einem Vortrag von Ingo Lütgebohle mit dem Titel Hop-Along Casualty.
Ingo hat sich beschäftigt mit automatischer Analyse von Videoüberwachung und dem Verhalten von Menschen. Wir müssen mal gucken.
Wie sich die Menschen in Reaktionen darauf verhalten? Also was sie für ein Ausweichverhalten zeigen? Oder die Auswertung ihres Verhaltens?
Genau, es geht um die Auswertung, also um die automatische Analyse.
Genau, vor ein paar Tagen hatten wir ja den Film The Catalog hier auch in den Podcast reingeworfen. Weiß nicht, ob ihr da schon mal einen Blick drauf geworfen habt. Wenn nicht, solltet ihr das mal tun. Das ist eine sehr schöne Vision von dem Chris Oakley, dem Künstler, der einfach mal so gezeigt hat, wie das so aussehen könnte. Ich habe das hier schon mal erwähnt, deswegen hake ich da nicht weiter drauf rum. Es geht ja auch weiter an dem Tag mit dem Thema mit einem Vortrag, der heißt Hacking CCTV. Das macht, glaube ich, die Wiener Fraktion.
Ja, von Quintessenz, der Martin und der Adrian.
Und die berichten über Maßnahmen, wie man sich gegen Kameraüberwachung, also CCTV, Circuit, Close Circuit Television, das ist ja so dieser gängige internationale Name, insbesondere in Britannien geprägt. Und ja, in dem Vortrag werden halt verschiedene Maßnahmen gezeigt, was man dagegen unternehmen kann, wenn man zu sehr überwacht wird. Und dann gibt es noch einen dritten, vom Axel Rüweller.
Ja, da geht es um eine Studie, die Überwachung an Hochschulen, da wurden an verschiedene Hochschulen, ich glaube 300 Stück oder so, wurden Fragebögen geschickt und ja zum Thema Überwachung und wie sie das irgendwie so finden, was sie tun und so weiter. Und Axel wird über die Ergebnisse dieser Umfrage berichten und auch so ein paar interessante Fragen beleuchten, die so in der Gesamtbefragung.
Die ist ja gar nicht so lange her, die Studie, die ist doch erst vor kurzem abgeschlossen worden.
Ja, es hat wohl begonnen im letzten Jahr, weil die Universität Paraborn einen Preis bekommen hatte.
Ja genau, den Preis, den Überwachungspreis, weil sie da am meisten überwacht haben. Und das war dein Ausgangspunkt für die Studie, oder?
Sobald ich das weiß, ja.
Ja, nächstes Thema ist Data Retention. Das ist wieder so ein Buzzword. Vorratsdaten-Speicherung ist der Begriff, der in Deutschland angeführt wird. Also Data Retention, um mal dazu erklären, es gibt halt jetzt den politischen Vorstoß. Ja, Vorratsdaten, das klingt viel zu positiv. Das ist so ein bisschen wie Entsorgungspark anstatt Müllhalde zu sagen. Unter Data Retention versteht man den Vorstoß, dass der Staat die Internet-Provider zwingt, den gesamten Datenverkehr, also alles, mitzuspeichern. Und nicht nur das, sondern auch mal für einen längeren Zeitraum. Und wir reden hier von Zeiträumen von ein bis zwei Jahren vorzuhalten. Das ist das absurde daran ist wieder, dass das mit vertretbarem Aufwand einfach überhaupt nicht machbar ist. Also sicherlich ist da irgendwas machbar, aber es kostet einfach Unmengen an Geld. Die letzten ist natürlich auf die Kunden abgewälzt werden. Und vor allem ist es einfach eine Unsitte, erstmal ohne konkreten Verdacht, einfach mal so für den Fall, dass man ja vielleicht mal irgendwo reinschauen möchte, für den Fall, dass irgendjemand vielleicht unter Umständen mit dem Internet irgendwas Böses tut, einfach mal alles zu speichern. Das ist ungefähr so, als würde man eben auch uns überall filmen, und überall aufschreiben, wo wir hingehen, für den Fall, dass man später noch mal rauskriegen möchte, was die Person X getan hat. Ja, und das ist jetzt mal nicht so ein blöder Film von irgendeinem Künstler, der das sich mal so ausgedacht hat, und das ist auch kein Buch von irgendeinem Schriftsteller vor 50 Jahren, sondern das ist einfach mal blanke, nackte Realität. Darüber wird geredet und vor allem bedrohlicherweise auf EU-Ebene, was ja ein sehr beliebtes Mittel ist, die nationalen Gesetzgebungen noch auszuhebeln und damit eben auch die gerade sensitivere deutsche Gesellschaft ein bisschen außen vor zu halten. Und wenn man jetzt nicht das Gefühl hat, dass die Regierung da besonders sensitiv gewesen wäre in letzter Zeit, aber unsere Bevölkerung, zumindest in Deutschland, ist es ja eigentlich schon. Das ändert sich leider unter dem Eindruck von Terror-Wahnsinn und ähnlichen Verpeilungen. Und ja, jetzt die Frage, was kann man dagegen tun? Dazu haben wir auch, seh ich das richtig, drei Vorträge. Geht los mit Hacking, Data Retention von Brenno de Winter. Was wird er dort vortragen?
Da geht es im Kern darum, was kann man tun, um welche einfache und auch etwas advancedere Möglichkeiten es gibt, um diese Form der Speicherraum-Adaptation zu führen. Also eben angefangen von Location, Wechseln über Tunneln und was weiß ich. Also er wird eine ganze Menge Sachen dazu sagen, wie man diese Form von Überwachung umgehen kann. Wir haben dann danach einen Vortrag von Marco Gerke, der am selben Tag noch einen Vortrag hält zum Thema Cybercrime Convention.
Dass dann aber mehr der juristische Auseinandersetzung erst beginnt.
Genau. Und sein Vortrag zum Thema Data Retention dreht sich um das nächste Level. Also wenn die Leute wirklich anfangen sollten zu verschlüsseln, ihre Nachrichten und so weiter.
Was sie tun werden.
Was sie tun werden, klar. Also sollten die...
Sollten, vielleicht schon tun. Genau, was sind die nächsten Bedrohungsszenarien? Also was wird offensichtlich das sein, was sie sich als nächstes einfallen lassen, wenn man erst mal anfängt, sich dagegen zu wehren?
Also was ich weiß, geht der so ein ganzer Schritt weiter, dieser Vortrag, weil es gibt ja schon konkrete Pläne für das nächste Level. Und darüber...
Wird er berichten.
Ja, das ist nicht hypothetisch. Also er hat da Einblick in das, was die Köpfe da sich ausspinnen. Auf EU-Ebene. Und das wird er dort vortragen. Und dann gibt es noch einen ähnlichen Vortrag, der insbesondere diese EU-Ebene klarer beleuchtet, von Klaus Langefeld, der beim EQEV, das ist so ein Verband der Internetprovider, aktiv ist. Und der berichtet ganz konkret über das, was dort politisch auf EU-Ebene abläuft.
Wer in den letzten Tagen die Nachrichten verfolgt hat, wird mitgekriegt haben, dass da jetzt alles wieder anders ist, weil die große Koalition von Sozialdemokraten oder Sozialisten im EU-Parlament und den Konservativen einen bestehenden Kompromissvorschlag gekippt haben. Und jetzt in der Vorbereitung tatsächlich sich jeden Tag auch etwas ändert und auf dem Kongress mal zum einen, was eben passiert ist und was jetzt gerade Stand sein wird in dem Fall. Also man weiß halt auch so bis in drei Wochen noch nicht genau, was besagen wird, wirklich entschieden sein wird. Ja.
Ja, damit sind wir eigentlich auch schon am Ende des ersten Tages angekommen. Also da gibt es natürlich noch sehr viel mehr Vorträge. Zwei, drei wollen wir noch mal kurz rauspicken, die jetzt nicht unter so einem großen Überthema stehen. Wem das nix sagt, piratebay.org ist ein doch sehr bekannter BitTorrent-Trekker-Suchserver, mit anderen Worten ein Ort, an dem extrem viele Wares ausgetauscht werden. Der steht wo noch mal genau? In Norwegen?
Aber in dem Fall kommt die Fraktion der Däden und der Schweden.
Aha, also eine skandinavische Verschwörung sozusagen. Und die berichten von ihren Erfahrungen, die sie so haben, aus ihrer Welt. Das wird sicherlich ganz interessant. Auch noch erwähnenswert, ein Vortrag unter dem Titel Hacking TomTomGo. Kennt ihr vielleicht TomTomGo? Das sind diese recht günstigen, auch vielseitigen durchaus ganz interessanten Produkte. TomTomGo, das ist ein Navigationssystem für das Auto. Packt man sich vorne drauf, funktioniert. Und dort wird auch Linux eingesetzt. Und deswegen sind die eben auch zur Veröffentlichung des Source Codes verpflichtet gewesen. Da gab es eine Auseinandersetzung. Da hat Harald Welte vom GPL Violations Projekt seinerzeit kräftig dazu beigetragen, dass dort ein bisschen Bewusstsein aufgebaut wurde. Mittlerweile gibt es da eine aktive Szene. Und wie man mit dem System arbeiten kann mit eigener Software und da Features einbauen kann, die die Standardversion nicht hat, wird in dem Vortrag berichtet. So, das war der erste Tag, das war schon jetzt sehr umfangreich. Man kommt da ja auch wirklich vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste. Zweiter Tag, gibt es weniger solche Metathemen, das alles ziemlich bunte Tüte. Auf jeden Fall interessant, der erste Vortrag eines Bundestagsabgeordneten auf dem Chaos Communication Congress von Jörg Taus, der schon länger dafür bekannt ist, sich insbesondere in der Datenwelt besser auszukennen als der Durchschnitts-Bundestagsabgeordnete. Sehr aufgeschlossener Mensch, der wird berichten über den Stand der Dinge zum Thema Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Dann hast du noch einen Vortrag, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Ja, da geht es um den Sony-Fall.
Das große Desaster. Sony entledigt dies Jahr einen Kunden ungefragt und unaufgefordert. Das werdet ihr mitbekommen haben, diese Rootkit-Geschichte. Also kurz gesagt, Sony verkauft Software, nein, Sony verkauft Musik, aber eigentlich ist es Software, die Leute sich dann auf ihrem PC installieren und damit fangen sie sich ein herbes Sicherheitsproblem ein.
Man müsste sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, als würde einfach jemand in die Wohnung einbrechen, den CD-Player auswechseln und die Fenster offen lassen. Also so in dem Stil ist das gelaufen.
Genau, und den CD-Player auch noch eigene Software mit. Die Fenster ausgehängt. Auch das kann man noch mal separat eingehen. Auf jeden Fall, der Vortrag wird es erklären. Jemand, der in dem Fall auch ganz konkret mitgeholfen hat, der letztes Jahr auch schon auf dem Kongress war und auch mal sehr beliebt ist auf Hacker-Konferenzen, Dan Kaminski, wird auch einen Vortrag geben zum Thema TCP IP Hacking, also Internet-Hacking im Allgemeinen. Dort Einblick gegeben, aktuelle Entwicklung. Er hat bei dem Sony-Fall auch dazu beigetragen, die Verbreitungszahlen dieses von Sony in die Welt gesetzten, kann man sagen Viruses dieser Software, die Sony dort einmal auf den Rechner installiert hat.
Ja, und so hat er was gemacht mit einer Technik, die sich DNS Cache Snooping nennt. Er hat einfach geguckt, welcher DNS-Server hat schon mal connected.sonymusic.com aufgerufen.
Und so hat er dann die Zahlen rausgefunden.
Genau, und so ist dann klar, in dem Netzwerk ist ein Rechner, der dieses Routen trägt.
Der weiß auf jeden Fall Bescheid. Ja, weiteres Highlight am zweiten Tag, Peter Glaser, langjähriges CCC-Mitglied, seines Zeichens Schriftsteller. Und nicht unerfolgreich ist unter anderem Ingeborg Bachmann, Preisträger, schreibt sehr schöne Bücher und war auch für das letzte Chaosradio vorgesehen, ist aber kurzfristig, muss er kurzfristig absagen, aber ich hoffe, er kommt bald wieder. Auf dem Kongress wird er einen Vortrag halten zum Thema das große Geheimnis, die Wiedereinführung von geheimen Aktivitäten weltweit seit dem 11. September. Ähnlich verwandt, aber passt ganz gut. Jakob Applebaum aus den USA wird zu uns kommen. Er hat eine interessante Geschichte durchlebt im letzten Jahr. Er war sowohl im Irak als auch in New Orleans, als die Überschwemmungskatastrophe dort stattfand nach dem Hurricane Katrina und hat sich unter anderem damit beschäftigt, Technologie in diese gestressten Regionen zu bringen und wird einen einen einen Bericht von vor Ort liefern und über seine Erfahrung, die er dort gemacht hat. Ach Gott, das ist so viel. Dann haben wir einen Mitarbeiter von Google, der zu uns kommt und der uns erklären wird, wie Google Maps funktioniert, beziehungsweise Google Local heißt das ja jetzt. Wurde ein bisschen unbenannt, also eine technische Einführung, auch für die Leute, die Interesse haben, sowas zu programmieren. Das kann sicherlich interessante Einblicke geben. Tatsächlich macht er zwei Vorträge, einen noch ein bisschen technisch und den hier eben zu Google Maps. Im Kulturbereich haben wir dann noch mal einen Vortrag zum Einfluss von Weblogs auf die Medienvielfalt von Johnny und Markus Becke dal, Johnny Häusler, einen Bekannten von Spreeblick und vom vorletzten Chaosradio auch. Markus Becke dal macht netzpolitik.org, den haben wir auch gleich nochmal in der Erwähnung. Ach, was haben wir denn hier noch für Highlights? Technological Art of the Trotten Tracks, das sind Yussi Angesläver und Regine, in Nachnamen vergesse ich immer wieder, egal, die macht das super tolle Weblog Remake Money Not Art, ganz großartig, eine exklusiv Quelle, die bloggt auch mit einer Vehemenz, dass man sich wundert, was sie eigentlich sonst den Tag über treibt, dazu ist sie noch die ganze Zeit am Rumreisen, also die schreiben alle mittlerweile bei ihr ab, das war... und die werden einfach über Medien Kunst berichten, die halt sehr techniklastig ist, quasi diese sanfte Konvergenz, die dort stattfindet, des künstlerischen und des technischen Bereichs, das wird sicherlich sehr aufschlussreich sein.
Ja, gleich im Anschluss daran, Korb vs. Korb.
Heißt, Industrie-Spionage, darum geht es. In dem Vortrag von zwei Italienern, das wird ein ganz bemerkenswerter Vortrag, ich hab den schon mal gesehen, in Malaysia vor ein paar Monaten. Das wird auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam.
Vielleicht noch als Info dazu, dass Roberto und Fabio, die den Vortrag halten, unter anderem so einen Edge betreiben. Das ist so ein Digital Defacement-Mirror, die also, wenn es Web-Defacements gab, da die Statements veröffentlichen. Und auch so eine Art frühe Bahnsystem haben, dass wenn einem die Seite, die Facebook, SMS oder so nachgeschrieben wird, dass es passiert ist.
Außerdem werden sie noch einen Hacker-Comic vorstellen auf dem Kongress, den sie extra für den Kongress produziert haben. Sie machen nämlich auch noch großartige Comics. Also von den Jungs ist einiges zu erwarten. Dann gibt es noch ein bisschen CCC-Aktivitäten. Der Lyrical-Wettbewerb des Chaos Computer Club Cologne.
Ja, da wären Maha, Jens und Henriette, die als Auswahlkomitee das Ganze auch begleitet haben, die Gewinner und die besten Sachen, die es gibt, da einfach vorstellen.
Also ein Nerd-Poesie wurde sozusagen angefordert. Es ist wohl auch einige gekommen und wir sind alle gespannt, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Ja, in der Nacht gibt es dann noch ein Capture the Flag. Da werden wir in der nächsten Sendung nochmal drüber berichten. Das ist so Hackersport, aber wir bleiben jetzt hier nochmal bei dem einigen Vortragsprogramm und schreiten mal zum dritten Tag. Und was haben wir da am dritten Tag?
Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Vortrag von Bert Boss, der beim W3C für so ein paar Standards sich verantwortlich zeichnet. Der hat sogar zwei Vorträge bei uns dieses Jahr. Also einmal einen zum Thema Web direkt jetzt.
Also W3C muss man dazu sagen, es ist das World Wide Web Konsortium, das ist quasi das Standardsgremium für alles, was mit dem World Wide Web zu tun hat. Dort wird also sowas wie HTML, HTTP, CSS definiert. Er ist auch selber ein CSS-Hacker, also diese Designsprache für das Web. Und er wird darüber berichten, wie sich solche Standards eben entwickeln und wie das W3C das eben sieht. Ja, der nächste interessante Vortrag, den ich hier sehe, ist betitelt mit IC Airplanes. Und das ist richtiger Hacksport. Eric Blossom, bekannt auch als Projektmanager von dem GNU Radio Projekt. Das ist quasi, wir erzeugen Frequenzen mit Software. Da kann man so ein eigenes Radio bauen, nur mit Software, da braucht man sonst sozusagen nicht viel. Und er wird allerdings jetzt weniger über GNU Radio berichten, sondern wie man sich sein eigenes Radar baut. Also wer schon immer mal Interesse hatte, den Himmel etwas abzuklopfen, wäre wahrscheinlich in diesem Vortrag gut untergebracht. Ja, und dann gibt es noch einen deutlichen Schwerpunkt.
Genau, er hat sich auch in den letzten Tagen erst als Schwerpunkt so richtig entwickelt. Wir hatten schon vor einer ganzen Weile jemanden aus Estland angefragt über das Internet-Voting, also über das Voting, was über Internet stattgefunden hat, in Estland. Und haben nach einigen Höhlen her sogar die Person gekriegt, die sich eigentlich verantwortlich zeichnet für die ganze Geschichte, nämlich Tavi Martens. Ja, und der wird halt darüber berichten. Davor gibt es noch einen Vortrag.
Wann das gelaufen ist, das Internet-Voting? Also in diesem Jahr.
Und davor gibt es noch einen Vortrag, der sich mit den deutschen Wahlmaschinen beschäftigt, von jemandem, der eine Klage anstrebt, weil die deutschen Wahlmaschinen...
Hat er auch schon, glaube ich, eingereicht, oder?
Ich bin mir da... Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht so genau, ob das schon passiert ist, aber ich denke, ja.
Ich denke schon. Also er fechtet die Bundestagswahl an, weil, was ja wenige Leute wissen, elektronische Wahlsysteme, also genau das, wo wir uns vor zwei Jahren in den USA noch so kräftig aufgeregt haben. Also nicht nur vor zwei Jahren, sondern schon vor sechs Jahren hat man sich aufgeregt, aber über die elektronischen hat man sich erst vor zwei Jahren richtig aufgeregt und sowas wird halt auch in Deutschland oder wurde in Deutschland bei der letzten Bundestagswahl in einigen Bezirken eingesetzt. Und interessanterweise haben diese Systeme ähnliche Nachlässigkeiten wie auch die amerikanischen. Und der Ulrich Wiesner wird in seinem Vortrag da drauf eingehen, was da falsch ist und wie das besser laufen soll. Ja, dann gibt es hier wieder unser kultureller Blog. Also was wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, ist ja, dass wir den Kongress so grob, aber auch wirklich grob in so fünf Teilbereiche einteilen. Wir haben halt einerseits den großen Bereich Hacking. Das ist auch der größte Teil, keine Frage. Ist ja ein Hacker-Kongress, aber beileibe nicht nur. Ein zweiter Teil ist halt Science. Wo alle wissenschaftlichen Vorträge, also alles das, was so deutlich in den akademischen und wissenschaftlichen Bereich reingeht. Da haben wir auch gleich noch was.
Wo es auch dieses Jahr sehr, sehr viel mehr gibt als im letzten Jahr.
Genau, eine Steigerung gab. Dann haben wir den Bereich Society, Gesellschaft. Das ist alles, was so mit Juristerei, Gesetzgebung und überhaupt Einfluss von Technologie auf die Gesellschaft zu tun hat. Dann haben wir noch unser Kulturprogramm. Alles, was sich zu kulturellen Sachen auseinandersetzt. Und einen vergesse ich immer.
Community.
Ah ja, genau. Und der Bereich Community, wo es eben um Gruppenbildung innerhalb der Szene geht, Aktivisten, Gruppen, die auch gegen bestimmte Gesetze vorgehen, ähnliches. Also alles, auch Softwareentwicklung, alles fällt da rein. Das sind so unsere grobe Sache. Und im Bereich Kultur haben wir hier noch Sprachen. Da haben wir uns nämlich sehr gewundert, als das eingereicht wurde. Haben wir aber dann auch genommen. Was ist das? Loibahn. Hab ich ja noch nie gehört. Kennst du das?
Also ich hab davon schon mal gehört, aber hab mich auch erst das erste Mal so richtig, das ist das erste Mal geklickt, sozusagen, als ich es von der Nase hatte. Es ist halt so eine artificielle Sprache, die sehr leicht zu erlernen sein soll, und zwar in nur wenigen Tagen.
Die sehr logisch aufgebaut ist.
Sehr logisch aufgebaut, mit sehr logischer Grammatik und nicht so wie im Deutschen, dass man eben wirklich Tausende von Regeln kennen muss, in die Sprache irgendwie einigermaßen sinnvoll zu sprechen. Ja, und dann haben wir noch einen zweiten Vortrag.
Zu dem Klassiker.
Zu dem Klassiker, genau.
Espiranto. Maha, Martin Hase wird da vortragen, seines Zeichens auch Professor in der, im Bereich.
Nee, nicht Martin trägt vor, sondern ich glaube, Palas trägt das vor.
Echt, jetzt bin ich aber durcheinander. Ach so, nee, stimmt ja. Du hast, du hast zu Recht, naja, stimmt. Genau, also da wird die Sprache Esperanto vorgestellt. Und wenn das was für euch ist, dann habt ihr schon wieder ein kleines Häkchen gemacht im Kongressprogramm. Ja, dann haben wir noch eine ganze Reihe, also die jetzt alle aufzuzählen, ich glaube, das würde hier wirklich zu weit führen. Aber, also nicht nur der dritte Tag, besonders der dritte Tag, aber eigentlich alle Tage sind durchwachsen mit hochtechnischen Vorträgen rund um Hackereien aller Art, insbesondere das Ausnutzen von Sicherheitslücken und derer gibt es ja nach wie vor viele. Aber am dritten Tag erwähnenswert finde ich noch, ach so viel, hier zum Beispiel Nils Boing, ziemlich bekannter Person aus der Wissenschaftsszene, Experte für Nanotechnologie, hat auch ein entsprechendes Buch geschrieben, was seinerzeit einen neuen Grund aufgemacht hat. Er wird eben auch über Nanotechnologie sprechen, bei uns auf dem Kongress. Dann haben wir noch einen Vertreter von Second Life da. Second Life ist ein in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig beachtetes, aber doch sehr interessantes 3D-Online-System, was so ein bisschen den Appeal von World of Warcraft hat. Aber hier geht es eben nicht um eine virtuelle Szenerie, wo man irgendwelche Zwerge erschlagen muss und vor Monstern davon laufen muss, sondern hier geht es eigentlich, wie der Name auch schon sagt, um die Eigengestaltung einer sozialen Welt, die sich eben Second Life nennt. Man kann dort eben mit virtueller 3D-Technik live in einem Netzwerk anderen Leuten spielen. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich es auch noch nicht ausprobiert habe. Die Zeit hat mir bislang gefehlt. Aber eine Einführung dazu wird es auch auf den Kongress gehen.
Also auf jeden Fall etwas mit einem extrem hohen Suchtpotenzial.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum ich es bisher so eingelassen habe. Ich habe ja schon genug Suchtpotenziale auf dem Tisch. Ja, Harald Welte, bekannt von seinen Aktivitäten GPL-Violations und auch Programmierer im Linux-Körner, wird vortragen, wie man aus einem Telefon mit freier Software sein eigenes Telefon nach Mars bauen kann oder bauen könnte.
Er hat übrigens am Tag 1 noch einen Vortrag zu RFID und...
Programmierung, genau. Programmierung von Systemen, die RFID auslesen. Aber am dritten Tag gibt es dann auch noch einen schönen... Vortrag im Saal 1 zum Thema Xbox und Xbox 360, also die jüngst vorgestellte Spielekonsole von Microsoft. Es geht aber nicht darum, wie man mit der Spielekonsole... spielen kann, sondern es geht darum, wie man auf dieser... Spielekonsole Linux installieren kann und überhaupt, wie man diese Maschine aufmacht. Das ist insbesondere sofern interessant. Also nicht nur interessant, weil es sich hier um ein System... handelt, was vergleichsweise wenig Geld kostet und weite... Verbreitung finden wird, wahrscheinlich. Hier geht es vor allem darum, dass es überhaupt möglich ist, obwohl sich Microsoft alle Mühe gibt, ihre Hardware so zu bauen, dass eben genau das nicht geht. Trotzdem haben die noch einen bemerkenswerten Speed... vorgelegt, also die Xbox 360 ist halt auch erst jetzt vor... zwei, drei Wochen vorgestellt worden und ich denke, wir werden auf dem Kongress erste Ergebnisse sehen. Die Sendung wird schon wieder viel zu lang, aber das muss jetzt alles mal raus. Danach machen wir es wieder ganz knapp alles. Versprochen. Der dritte Tag, haben wir noch was? Hexenbesen lese ich hier. Hexenbesen und Heiliger Gral. Das klingt doch toll.
Ja, und zwar ist das ein Vortrag von Henriette, die ja gerade ein Buch veröffentlicht hat über die Wikipedia und auch darüber, über die Wikipedia einen Vortrag hält, und zwar vor allem über die inhaltliche Qualität. Jetzt gerade, Wikipedia ist auch ein heißes Thema gerade. Ein sehr heißes Thema, weil in Amerika Artikel von Leuten erschienen sind, beziehungsweise von Leuten editiert wurden und Leuten irgendwie den Mord an John F. Kennedy mitunterschieben und so.
Ja, einem sogar recht renommierten Journalisten, also dem auch keiner was unterstellen wollte. Es wurden auch schon erste Maßnahmen ergriffen, von denen man noch nicht so genau weiß, ob das überhaupt irgendeinen Sinn haben wird. Interessanterweise sind das auch Maßnahmen, die nur in der englischen Wikipedia ergriffen wurden bislang. Die deutsche Wikipedia unterscheidet sich auch stark von der englischen, insofern, als dass sie eigentlich die aktivste Wikipedia ist, im Vergleich zu der Zahl der Muttersprachler. Aber auch das müssen wir noch mal verschieben. Wikipedia soll auf jeden Fall im nächsten Chaosradio Express noch ein Thema sein. Und damit haben wir doch jetzt erstmal den dritten Tag hinter uns gebracht und dürfen die große Seite weiter blättern.
Ja, was vielleicht noch interessant ist, dass wir haben zwar das Key Signing aus dem Programm rausgenommen, also aus dem offiziellen Programm, weil im letzten Jahr...
Du meinst die Key Signing Party.
Die Key Signing Party, ja. Es wird von Des Hardy einen Vortrag über das Web of Trust gehen, was dahintersteckt, was funktioniert, was nicht funktioniert. Und danach wird es halt so oft wieder eine Key Signing Party geben.
Mal kurz erläutern, was hier gemeint ist. Also PGP oder GPG, das ist die am weitesten verbreitetste Technik im Internet, um E-Mails zu verschlüsseln und generell auch Dateien zu verschlüsseln. Ein dem System zugrunde liegendes Konzept ist das Web of Trust, also ein gegenseitiges Vertrauensmodell, was dazu beitragen soll, dass man eben verschlüsselt versendeten Nachrichten mehr Vertrauen entgegenbringen kann. Key Signing Parties werden von uns da etwas kritisch betrachtet, deswegen haben wir das jetzt auch nicht offiziell mit ins Programm aufgenommen. Warum wir das so problematisch sehen, das wird dann der Vortrag von Seth Hardy hoffentlich beleuchten.
Es gibt auch einen schönen Eintrag im Public Wiki dazu.
Auf der pgp-keysigning-party-seite. Okay, dann blättern wir jetzt aber um. Soll ich mal so ein Umblättergeräusch machen hier?
Robert Gerrer und Markus Beckethal zu Wesens.
WSIS, das ist der World Summit on Information Society, war vor ein, zwei Wochen heißes Thema, weil da fand dieser Summit statt, jahrelang geplant gewesen. Und dort geht es sozusagen um die, ja, die Informationsgesellschaft. Und absurderweise wurde diese Konferenz an einem Ort abgehalten, wo man eigentlich von einer Informationsgesellschaft nicht wirklich sprechen kann, nämlich in Tunesien. Markus Bekedahl hat unter netzpolitik.org live von der Veranstaltung berichtet, extrem viele dazu gepostet, das kann man ihm einzeln nicht wiedergeben, aber Markus wird hier demnächst auch noch mal Gast sein bei Chaosradio Express, dann werden wir uns darüber noch unterhalten. Zusammenfassung der Veranstaltung dort in Tunesien und die Auswirkungen, die davon zu erwarten sind, werden also am vierten Tag in einem Vortrag gegeben. Man sagt immer, wenn man nicht weiter weiß. Was haben wir denn noch? Bluetooth-Hacking steht im Mittelpunkt am vierten Tag. Das ist eine Fortführung eines Vortrags, den wir schon im letzten Jahr hatten, von der gleichen Gruppe, von Leuten. Also ein Update zum Thema Bluetooth und Bluetooth-Sicherheit vor allem. Dort werden also alle aktuellen Hacks gezeigt, wie man auf Mobiltelefone und andere portable Geräte, die über diese Technik verfügen, zugreifen kann. Aber auch wie man programmieren kann, welche neuen Dienste und Trends es dort gibt. Das nimmt auch, glaube ich, zwei Stunden ein, der Vortrag, oder?
Interessant auf jeden Fall noch ein Vortrag, über dessen Thema wir selber nur sehr wenig wissen, und zwar über Quantenverschränkungen, nenn sich Quantum Entanglement von der Stefanie Wehner.
Quantenverschränkung.
Nicht-Ordlichkeit und so eine Sache.
Genau, High-Tech Science, vorgetragen von Stefanie Wehner.
Ja, das ist halt ein Einführungsvortrag, der überhaupt so Quanteneffekte beschreibt und so. Ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Einstieg in die Welt der Quanten. Da gibt es noch einen schönen Vortrag zu Freenet. Kannst du zu Freenet noch kurz was sagen?
Ja, Freenet ist ein Netzwerk, in dem anonymisiert Daten getauscht werden können. Es wird auf dem Kongress ein Release einer neuen Version geben. Und ein Clark und Oskar Sandberg, der zweite Hauptentwickler, werden da sein und so ein paar Sachen vorstellen, die jetzt neu sind und die sich geändert haben. Es geht da weiter.
Ist natürlich auch schön, noch mal im Kontext von Data Retention zu nennen. Also ist ja klar in dem Moment, wo alle alles mitspeichern und mal wirklich Angst haben muss, dass alles durchsucht wird, also begründet Angst haben muss. Sind vollverschlüsselte Netzwerke eigentlich der nächste Schritt?
Naja, wobei das ja bei Freenet eher um, also darum geht, Dinge zu publizieren. Also dass ich in Netzwerken publizieren kann, ohne als Publizierender erkannt zu werden.
Also anonymes Veröffentlichen.
Ganz genau.
Dann haben wir noch was zum WLAN, also Wiredislan, im Einsatz auf eine Art und Weise, wie es nicht gedacht war. Unter dem Titel Wifi Longshots berichtet Elektra, Elektra Wagenrad. Echt viele Frauen diesmal im Vortragsprogramm. Was für Damen zahlen?
22 Stück. Wir haben ja noch so ein paar Slots für Late Breakerinnen.
Okay, also der Vortrag Wifi Longshots befasst sich mit WLAN-Technik im Einsatz für lange Strecken. Wie kann man also mit normaler WLAN-Technik und da mit geringem Finanzaufwand und geringem Bastelaufwand lange Strecken überbrücken? Außerdem macht sie, glaube ich, noch einen Vortrag zu OLSR, also zu diesem alternativen Routing-Protokoll, was man auch über WLAN verwenden kann, was eben jetzt nicht dem Standard-WLAN entspricht, was eine andere Charakteristik zeigt.
Es gibt jetzt noch einen dritten Vortrag dazu, der sich mit dem günstigsten VRT beschäftigt und wie man das Ding hackt. Das ist einer der meistverkauften Linux-Dibases überhaupt, glaube ich, und da wird es sowohl einen Vortrag als auch einen Workshop geben.
Also dieser kleine WLAN-Router, den die Firma Linksys vertreibt. Ja, dann gibt es noch hier noch was Schönes für Hacker. Pocket TCP ist ein Projekt, wo TCP IP, also die Basis-Software vom Internet, noch mal komplett neu programmiert wurde in Python, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das hat schlicht und ergreifend den Sinn, dass man einen sehr leicht zugänglichen Code hat, der im Prinzip alles tut, um damit besser experimentieren und forschen zu können, als das jetzt möglich wäre mit dem in die Betriebssystem eingebauten TCP IP, weil da kommt man nicht so ohne weiteres ran, das ist so der Kernel, das ist nicht so einfach. Aber diese Software steckt komplett in den eigenen Programmen mit drin und kann man eben sehr einfach verwenden. Auch dazu einen Vortrag am vierten Tag auf dem Kongress. Und dann kommt FX, renommierte Hacker-Personen, hier auch aus Berlin, auch schon mehrfach auf dem Kongress gewesen, immer wieder zu Gast, nimmt den BlackBerry auseinander. Der ist ja eh schon tot, oder? BlackBerry ist dieses kleine, ich lese meine E-Mail überall, die weiß, was extrem populär ist, aber in letzter Zeit eigentlich aus allen Firmen und Organisationen rausfliegt, weil die Sicherheitsmücken dermaßen eklatant sind. Denen frage ich jetzt keiner. Ich glaube sogar die Bundeswehr hat jetzt auch das Untersagen, ob ich da was in den falschen Hals kriege.
Vielleicht meinen das und die haben auch Probleme mit Patentstreitigkeiten, aber wie es halt so ist, da ja die amerikanische Administration die Dinge wohl auch im Einsatz hat oder wie auch immer. Also wenn es ein Interesse daran hat, dass RIM keine Probleme hat, gibt es da halt auch, anders als bei anderen Sachen, irgendwie keinen sofortigen Shutdown bzw. noch keine Regelung, also ein ganz schräger Fall an sich.
Schauen wir mal, wie das nach dem Vortrag aussieht.
Ja, außerdem hat FX ja auch was lustiges entdeckt von unserer Webseite. Also durch sozusagen unsere Webseite und zwar ein Stack Overflow.
Im Internet Explorer, das habe ich im letzten Express schon berichtet. Bleiben wir nochmal bei den Vorträgen. Es gibt da noch ein paar schöne Sachen. Andreas Lange vom Computerspielemuseum, hier auch schon in Berlin recht bekannte Person daher, gibt uns einen Vortrag über die Entwicklung der Spielekultur, so in der Frühzeit. Also ein historischer Vortrag, Computerspiele historischer Vortrag. Und dann gibt es noch einen schönen Bereich zum Thema Accessibility, insbesondere Linux für Blinde und Behinderte im Allgemeinen. Da gibt es mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Projekte. linnaccess.org steckt hier im Wesentlichen dahinter. Es gibt ja diverse Linux-Distributionen, speziell auch für Blinde. Blinux ist da so ein Thema. Es gibt eine angepasste Version von Knopfix. Also alles, was damit zu tun hat, auch das wird auf dem Kongress vorgestellt. So, jetzt sind wir fast durch. Du hattest hier noch den WarGames Vortrag, den du noch vorstellen wolltest.
Was ich noch ganz schön finde, das ist ein Vortrag von Franzis Hunge. Der wollte schon im letzten Jahr eigentlich kommen, was dann kurz vor sich nicht mehr geklappt hat. Da geht es um Identitätskonstruktionen von Hackern, und zwar anhand des Films WarGames, wo ja der gute, nette Junge erst so Zensuren ändert und später dann mit Norath Spielchen spielt.
Auf jeden Fall eine der prägendsten Kulturelemente für die heutige Sichtweise des Wortes Hacker.
Ja, und Franzis hat ein paar ganz interessante Betrachtungen. Ich will das auch eigentlich gar nicht vorwegnehmen, weil das sollte man sich einfach wirklich angucken.
Genau, nun machen wir das jetzt auch nicht. Also es ist interessant, müsst ihr euch unbedingt anschauen. Ja, und am Schluss gibt es da noch eine ganze Menge andere Sachen. Wir haben jetzt vor allem die ganzen Klassiker weggelassen. Also es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe von Vorträgen, die jetzt Leute, die häufiger beim Kongress sind, ohnehin schon kennen, die dann immer wieder in einer Neuauflage das aktuelle Geschehen reflektieren. Das findet ihr alles im Fahrplan. Eins davon ist zum Beispiel das Network Review. Das ist ein Bericht von unserem NOC, also von unserem Network Operations Center. Also die Leute, die für das Netzwerk auf dem Kongress zuständig sind. Und die werden berichten, wie das so dieses Jahr gelaufen ist. Wir werden da neue Anstrengungen sehen, insbesondere diese WLAN-Problematik in den Griff zu bekommen. Ist immer wieder so ein heißes Ding, wird dann auch immer ganz gerne heiß diskutiert und lalala. Und das WLAN hat nicht funktioniert. Na ja, das ist, was soll man dazu noch sagen? Also auf so einer Veranstaltung wie dem Kongress ein funktionierendes Netzwerk hinzubekommen, ist eigentlich fast unmöglich. Das hat einfach damit zu tun, dass so viele Leute dort mit Rechnern da sind. Also allein die Dichte, wir haben sogar auf dem Camp haben wir, glaube ich, pro Teilnehmer 1,1 Computer gezählt. Also es gibt immer deutlich mehr Rechner als Teilnehmer. Bei 3.500 Leuten kann man sich in etwa vorstellen, insbesondere wie hoch der Laptop-Anteil ist. Und alle wollen dann natürlich wireless laden machen. Also so eine Kapazität, das ertragen schon die wenigsten Systeme.
Ja und dazu sind ja auch so im Kongress eben auch ein Haufen Leute, die sich mit Netzwerksicherheit und mit Netzwerkenpenetrationen und so auseinandersetzen und das halt auch mal gleichmäßig ausprobieren.
Ja und natürlich dort vor Ort. Und das ist halt eines der Probleme und dagegen anzugehen, da sind schon viele Probleme, viele Ansätze verfolgt worden, die auch alle so kleine Teil-Erfolge haben, aber um das in der Summe zum Laufen zu kriegen, das ist eine echte Herausforderung. Dieses Jahr gibt es einen weiteren Versuch und alle sehr motiviert und wir werden sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Und wenn es nicht klappt, stören wir da auch nicht von. Am Ende zählt immer der Spaß am Gerät und das Ausprobieren und überhaupt ist Technologie kein Zustand, sondern ein Prozess, an dem man gerne teilhaben möchte. Und wer Lust hat, daran teilzuhaben, so wie wir daran teilhaben, der sollte sich jetzt nochmal auf events.ccc.de umschauen, ein bisschen in unserem Webblog blättern, vielleicht auch mal ins Wiki schauen und sich doch überlegen, auf den Kongress zu kommen. Denn dort ist es lustig. Und es gibt vor allem echt viel interessante Leute dort zu treffen. Schräge Vögel und Leute, die wirklich Plan haben. Ja, jetzt haben wir dann doch einen deutlich umfangreicheren Überblick über das Kongressprogramm gegeben. Damit haben wir das aber jetzt auch mal abgerissen. Das ist auch gut. Ihr seht schon, es gibt eine Menge zu erzählen. Wir könnten jetzt eigentlich auch noch eine Stunde weiterreden, machen wir aber nicht, sondern wir machen jetzt hier einfach mal Schluss. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören, wenn ihr es soweit geschafft habt. Nächste Chaosradio Express gibt es dann in wenigen Tagen. Und ich verspreche, das wird dann ein bisschen kürzer.